Why?
Why is there so much hate in the world?
We should all just love each other.
Johnny (The Room): What makes you say that?
If a lot of people love each other...
The world will be a better place to live
- think about that.
But no, y'all just gotta hate!
J: What makes you say that?
I made a respectful video talking about
my favourite YouTuber. Just look at all the dislikes.
I'm gonna read some of the comments,
Just so you understand the pain and  suffering I have to endure as a YouTuber
so you understand the pain and suffering I have to endure as a
And remember,
J & F: If a lot of people loved each other
the world would be a better place to live
Haha, you think you're funny hell no. This video is just for views to pay your rent for this month
[Reading] Haha you think you're funny... hell no.
*gunshot* Felix: Ah
[Reading] This video is just for views to pay your rent for this month.
*realizes he's been found out*
F: *maniacal laugh*
(feel free to laugh along)
This nibba thinks I pay rent ??? PFT.
*nervous laughter*
That's cute
Edgar: Well if you're so rich, why don't you pay for food?
Shut the fuck up
I WILL END YOU
(FELIX NO)
I WILL DESTROY YOU
[Reading] Bleep *chuckles* off, first Nick is not fat and second Jake Paul is always going to be better than you.
F: You know it always especially hurts
when they have an avatar
of a furry wolf-angel.
(oh dear)
[Reading] Get fucking rext becaa- becase I'm
I'm maverick bish.
(the grammar is just-)
F: There's so much-
*laughs* There's so much wrong with
this comment, I don't know where to begin.
[Reading] Leave Jake Paul alone, man.
You act like you're the best YouTuber. If I had to pick my favorite YouTubers, I wouldn't- it wouldn't be you.
*burps and yells out with sad piano music playing*
F: ooOoOhH NnnOOoo
Come on, man. Ehh, ahh,
At least top five! Please top ten, I'll
take a top ten from you, Nathan! Please!
[Reading] Jake Paul is the best b*tch.  *laughs*
F: The comma, it's important.
You basically called Jake Paul the best bitch.
[Reading] Stop pausing it
and by the way Jake Paul roasted you so much.
I described to them so much and you're next, Pewdiepie, Time10 is looking for you
Shit. NO! Not tIME10! ANYONE, but Time10!
[Reading] And you're a dick
*gunshot*  F: AaaaAaAHhHhH!
Aha ah ahhhhhhh got 'em!
[Reading] If you're a Jake Paulers like this post.
(1 like lmao)
*sad piano music playing*
[Reading] How can do many people like this guy?
His not even funny!!
F: How can do many people?
How can do many people like this guy?
I may not be funny but this comment is hilarious (laughs)
[Reading] Fuck you, peEDIEPEAR
[Reading] Oh my God, Pewdiepie
You are such a bully you should be talking Jake Paul
not the rest of the Team10, members
you have no freakin right to talk about Nick Crompton saying that he's
fat, just like I have no right to tell you you're ugly
but I'm saying it because you die- die- serve it
F: Man, Taylor Munoz goes hard. Holy shit. And I'm-I'm sorry. I apologize to Nick Crompton.
He is the most beautiful specimen I've seen in my life.
I wanna dip him in frying oil.
You know who is fat? You're not funny, stop lyyyiiiing! You're so baaad!
You're DUMP!
Jake Paul is better than youuu!
You should quit youtube stop saying bad words my friend said if you say bad words, you're gust saying it, [too]
You're saying it to you self, and you mean
Devil face devil face devil face devil face devil face favel face angry face angry face angry face--- Jesus Chri-
It's kind of cute. I kinda- It's kinda cute, this comment.
Please watch Logan's diss track
Logan: cuz yeah my brother messed up
but he still got his Disney contract
OOH! OOH SHIT!!
The Paulers go hard.
Fuck I really wish I still had that Disney contract
Song: Kids Table Kids Table Giant TV.
Ok  that was kind of better...
*Pewds having mild anneurism*
I don't know why you didn't post this  one Jake, this rap is way better.
"Kid's table, kids table, the place to be"
AAH
"Don't you agree?"
KIDS TABLE KIDS TABLE - NO PLACE TO BE
Song: KIDS TABLE KIDS TABLE, her name is Brie
so- so fucking lit
AH! So good FUCK the- (grunts)
Had to pull the Disney contract card goddamit
Comment: "At least he knows how to rap"
That's right uh, Kendrick Lamar.
At least JP knows how to rap
Guys don't judge JP without fully comprehending his INTENSE and RAW talent
if you think that being on Disney is lame
Hell no, I never think- I never thought that
S:"And we wished on a star and a snowman came to life"
"KIDS! TABLE! KIDS! TABLE! EFUJCEUCI!"
Oh, wait. I'm sorry your videos only get 1 to 4 million views, but this one got 10 million for having Jake's name
Is it fucking unbelievable
No, you're right. I really have barely any videos over 10 million, so
It's really a struggle, and [I] really need to put people's name in the title
Jake might actually be the best You-YouTuber maybe better than you Pewds
he gained 5 million subs in six months. That's more than 500..
*chuckles* That's more than 500 thousand subs per month, per month...
Because you know I've never Gained 5 million subs
In six months that has never happened more than once
it just
I've never been fortunate enough because it's never done before you know I never got 10 million subs in 6 months as well
That has never been done before
your content is shit, shut the fuck up you handicapped motherfucker
AHA
damn
People got really mad, huh, Jesus
cannot stand how pewdiepie thinks he's funny.He's cringy. I love JAKE
He's just mad because Jake is getting more views than him
He's talking about nick, but pewdiepie looks starving
if he wants to talk about others, he sould make his own diss track
He's retarded if anyone is he just put jake's name down so he could... (pewds mumbling the rest of the shitty comment)
(Even more mumbling)
I hope he makes a video after this on hate comments
Well I did actually
I don't like Ubu talking about Jake Paul and bla bla bla Bla Bla Bla Bla Bla Bla Bla Bla stop talking about other
YouTubers because you're not the boss, and you rule all over and you rule all the [other] youtubers [ah] that's nice
That's cool. You don't rule
AH ! FUCK!
Literally this was dumb Jake and the whole team made the lyrics in a music video in One day
And it was all a joke
I think felix is just jealous because Jake can actually make a song I've made songs in a day, right
I made many of them. They're not great either, but at least I don't fucking flaunt like I'm tough shit for it
Could he be- The one?
when you don't wanna wear
female underwear when you don't even care what other people say, I've done a lot of SHIIT
JUST FOR ATTENTION
GIVE ME ATTENTION
I don't reaIly wanna wear that. I don't really wanna overreact. I don't wanna make a video with a twat
I don't really wanna eat that
Dude Pewdiepie
Parentheses, you're like 57 Years old get a life
Unironically you look 57 as well
what the fuck (laughs)
I like how he skipped the only two parts of the song Martinez twins and Chase's part that wasn't complete trash well, we wait
Basically most of it was cut because I was so fucking fed up. I was so sick when I shot that video
I was literally feeling terrible I didn't even want to shoot it. I was going way too hard on it and in
reality I don't care like it [I]
Think it's an objectively bad video. It's kind of like fun to make fun. It's like the room
J:"What makes you say that?"
it's fun to laugh at
I don't- like have any grudge or hate or anything
But everyone just got so fucking like all these kids to go crazy about it
Look, I know you're the king of youtube, but fuck you. I'm Jake Pualer for life fuck you
Fuck you, I fucking hate you. I wish you would die
That's a nice one.
Pewdiepie, shut the fuck up bro your youtube name is GAY
Pewdiepie the fuck is that BRO?!
Can't you find someone?
Something else than Pewdiepie at least JakePaul has a normal name and then you try to rap, bro
You had me dying just don't try rap again and fix your eyes. That's a gun, bro
Not a dick [goddamnit] you gotta check out your eyes aren't you rich bro?
You bitch can't afford to fix your eyes (laughs) and then you try to make fun of (pewds laughing)
Oh he's
[Kobe's] friend nah, bro your trip and that shit is messed up nobody gives two [fucks]
If he's fat or [not] bet he gets more bitches than you
like look at yourself
And then talk bro you you look gay? You sound gay, and you think all of that could you guys (WTF ?!! )
Okay I can't
I'm- (SIGHS)
I'm glad that I didn't watch a YouTube channel
What what are you trying to say? Oh, I'm glad I didn't watch her YouTube channel
who do you what are you talking about
YOUR
Like I don't actually care
There seems to be so much drama going on and like all these drama channels
It's so easy to get swept into it
I get it
You make 9 videos about it
and then they call you out for
For milking it by putting your name in the title for views but then you do the exact same thing yourself
[it's] easy, you know it's easy views obviously you're going to take it Jp. I get it
I used to be cancer as well
Extremely cancer isn't I used to have a really young fan base as well, and I think
When when you had a young fan, base they really they really look at you differently
They don't criticize you if you make mistakes, and they're very forgiving which is a really nice thing
But it kind of gets you blindsided for when you make False
Speaking from experiences first time that I ever received hate on YouTube
I got completely blind [set] as well, and my response to that was literally-
Ah Well Fuck You
I still make more money than you and you're just bringing me views because you're hating on me
and I kind of see the same response from Jake and the Paul gang from all this and
You know what  if that's what they want to do that. That's all fine, but it's very arrogant and it's very
Childish, and I know that because I used to be arrogant, and I used to be childish, so I get it
I really don't care for drama. I don't care for beef. I don't care about anything
AHAHAHA
If I see stuff [that's] fun to react to I'm going to do it
Anyway, that's it for me for now
See you see you later my family.
Which I love so dearly <3
You guys are like my family.
Now excuse me because I have other [business] to
take care of I'm a very busy youTuber
S: got hydraulics it was worth the enormous price
(pewds jamming)
then we wished on a star and a snowman came to life
kids table kids table the place to be
kids table kids table. Don't you agree kids table kids table the place to be
Dab on them haters